[Music]
so this apartment will be our base for
the duration of the mission thank you to
the vulture for procuring it it all
thank me thank my boy Billy said the
place is mine while he's still in prison
I saw what it sounds like his only crime
was planning at kick-ass Music Festival
are you friends with the fire festival
guy best friends he got a bum rap you
can learn about it when my documentary
comes out it points all the blame where
it clearly belongs with the island
people Wow
so many levels of terrible they're all
right we need to catch Kelli on the act
of illegally spying so here's the plan
we commit a fake crime so serious that
he's forced to deploy the Stingray what
kind of crime we're gonna kidnap a cop
but not just any cop it needs to be
someone so high ranking that it sends
shockwaves through the system but not
important enough that their absence
negatively impacts the NYPD in any way
you guys thinking we're clearly all
looking at you oh god am I in charge of
the meeting dismissed dismissed no
you're getting kidnapped CJ Amy Charles
and I will be the kidnappers captain
Holt is the driver here's how it'll go
down approaching the target area let's
do this masks on actually scratch that
we're not gonna use ski masks we'll use
cool rubber masks we should be the
ladies of the First Wives Club
I call Kate we're not gonna do First
Wives Club masks it's because it can't
be Keaton grow up Jake ooh because they
don't exist and also yeah Keaton is
clearly the coolest one and I don't
think it's really fair that you just
called her don't forget it will we're
scary gorilla masks approaching the
target okay let's do this masks on but
CJ goes to get his morning coffee we
will arrive and grab him he will pretend
to struggle just enough to attract
attention
we write this down so I remember my
lines I can see that you already have
the word milk written on your hand I
know where this is going
milk don't do that too risky what if you
leave DNA evidence at the scene well
luckily it's a missing-persons case so
the lead detective will be the vulture
he will arrive and no no no hold on
Peralta you forgot to say that I write
in on my motorcycle
okay the vulture who rode in on his
motorcycle Colby will take charge and
eliminate any evidence we left behind
there's nothing here make sure the other
people working with you or your worst
detectives I got just the guys for you I
mean the real duds I wouldn't even trust
this to to get coffee from me all right
tell him over at Brooklyn you know you
guys take off all right I got this right
hey you know do I tell me what you saw
tell you what I'd like to see your big
stop I'm the one describing the place so
it's not gonna be any sex at all no the
point is without any good leads Kelly
will give the order to use the Stingray
an order that we will record thanks to
our very own madeline wuntch you're not
possible Kelly won't tell me anything
he won't even meet with me perhaps you
can sneak in disguised as an old leather
chair will you calm down
she works at one Police Plaza all you
have to do is run into it mr. Kelly no
Madeline I didn't see you there
I thought you were an old leather chair
he's not gonna say that but you're worse
than the vulture anyway give him a
handshake pat on the back I heard your
app caught a serial killer ha clues
strikes again yes indeed II can plant
the bug and that's the plan that is
exactly how tomorrow's gonna go got it
so you do you don't want me to you'll
know
you